Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by APA CEO Arthur C. Evans, Jr., who's here to talk about our Stress in America Report that was released at the end of October, and the findings are quite stark. 69% of American adults report significant stress about our nation's future, and it's not just them. teens and young adults in Generation Z are also reporting significant stress about issues like mass shootings, school shootings, sexual assault, and news headline issues like immigration. Welcome, Dr. Evans.
欢迎收听美国心理学会的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天我邀请到了美国心理学会首席执行官亚瑟·C·埃文斯博士，他将与我们讨论十月底发布的《美国压力报告》，其中的发现非常严峻。69%的美国成年人表示对国家未来感到巨大的压力，而且不仅是他们，Z世代的青少年和年轻人也对大规模枪击事件、校园枪击、性侵犯以及移民等新闻头条问题感到巨大的压力。欢迎您，埃文斯博士。
Thank you. Glad to be here. There's a lot happening in the country and the world right now, and it's clearly affecting the health for young people. What is the state of the mental health of our young people today in Generation Z? Well, what our survey found is that young people are experiencing a significant amount of stress, and it's related to a number of things that are happening. in our society. While young people are not, and we refer to them as Generation Z, that's the age group between 15 and 21, while they're not experiencing different stressors, they are experiencing those stressors at a greater intensity than the rest of the population. So we're concerned about that, and we're also concerned that when we ask about their mental health and the state of their
谢谢。很高兴来到这里。目前国家和世界上发生了很多事情，这显然影响了年轻人的健康。今天Z世代年轻人的心理健康状况如何？我们的调查发现，年轻人正承受着巨大的压力，这与我们社会中发生的许多事情有关。虽然年轻人——我们称之为Z世代，即15到21岁的人群——并没有经历不同的压力源，但他们感受到的压力强度比其他人群更大。所以我们对此感到担忧，我们也担心当我们询问他们的心理健康状况时，
mental health, young people that age groups actually say that their mental health is fair or poor at a greater rate than other generations. And so what are some of the unique stressors that this generation faces today? One of the things that we're concerned about is that while Generation Z is experiencing the same things as older generations, they are not as equipped to deal with that. First of all, from a developmental standpoint, you know, our executive, functioning, the part of the brain that controls that, isn't fully developed until age 25. And so on the one hand, you have this generation that is experiencing the same stressors as
心理健康状况，该年龄段的年轻人表示其心理健康状况为一般或较差的比例高于其他世代。那么，这一代人今天面临的一些独特压力源是什么？我们担心的一点是，虽然Z世代经历着与老一辈相同的事情，但他们应对这些问题的能力不足。首先，从发育角度来看，我们的执行功能，即大脑中控制这一功能的部分，要到25岁才完全发育成熟。因此，一方面，这一代人经历着与其他人相同的压力源，
everyone else, but developmentally, they haven't developed, they haven't fully maturated and don't have all the skills that they need from that standpoint. So, for example, the issue of mass shootings, Generation Z reports that as a stressor at a greater rate than the rest of the population significantly. They're concerned about school shootings, which is something that is going to affect them more than other groups. They're also concerned about things like social media. One of the interesting things in the survey is that half of the people, about half of that generation, see social media as a support and something that's positive, and the other half see it as something that can be a stressor. So we know social media, a lot of the
但从发育角度来看，他们尚未完全成熟，没有具备从该角度出发所需的所有技能。例如，关于大规模枪击事件的问题，Z世代报告将其视为压力源的比例明显高于其他人群。他们担心校园枪击事件，这对他们的影响比其他群体更大。他们还担心社交媒体等问题。调查中一个有趣的发现是，大约一半的年轻人将社交媒体视为一种支持和积极的事物，而另一半则认为它可能是一种压力源。所以我们知道社交媒体，
concerns that they have about what's happening in the news, issues like immigration, issues like suicide, those kinds of issues are also stressors for them. And social media, as you said, does play a role because that's something that wasn't around as much for millennials or it wasn't around at all for Generation X or previous generations too. That's correct. So social media and school shootings. That was something that people in my generation didn't worry about, but is clearly a stressor
他们对新闻中发生的事情的担忧，比如移民问题、自杀问题，这些也是他们的压力源。正如你所说，社交媒体确实发挥了作用，因为这在千禧一代中并不那么普遍，或者对于X世代或更早的世代来说根本不存在。没错。所以社交媒体和校园枪击事件。这是我这一代人不需要担心的事情，但显然是当今年轻人面临的压力源。
for young people today. So about 7 out of 10 Generation Z respondents reported laying awake at night because of stress. But what are some of the other physiological signs of stress that manifest in teens and young adults? Not only are teens laying awake at night, but they are also experiencing physical and mental symptoms. And in fact, 90% reported at least one symptom in the past month. That is a very high number. So, you know, we're concerned about the level of symptoms that young children. that young people are experiencing this generation.
大约70%的Z世代受访者表示因压力而彻夜难眠。那么，在青少年和年轻人身上表现出的其他生理压力迹象有哪些？青少年不仅彻夜难眠，还经历着身体和心理症状。事实上，90%的人报告在过去一个月内至少出现过一种症状。这是一个非常高的数字。所以，我们对这一代年轻人所经历的症状水平感到担忧。
The other kinds of symptoms that they might be experiencing are disturbances in eating, disturbances in sleep, reporting headaches, those are the kinds of physical symptoms that often are an indication that people are experiencing stress. And so what can parents and other people do to help these young people to not be so stressed and to make their lives a little bit easier? You can do a lot of things. So one of the things to do is to really be clear about what are the things that are creating
他们可能经历的其他症状包括饮食紊乱、睡眠障碍、头痛，这些都是人们承受压力的常见生理迹象。那么，父母和其他人可以做些什么来帮助这些年轻人减轻压力，让他们的生活变得轻松一些呢？你们可以做很多事情。其中之一就是真正明确是什么在制造压力。
stress. And I think the survey is actually one of the things that's helpful in that because we sort of lay out. These are the things that young people are most concerned about and are causing stress for people. But it's also important for people to understand that things like social support, we have literally decades of research that shows that the more people that we have in our level, we have lives that support us, generally the better our health is, generally the better our mental health is, and frankly, the better we do in life. And so we can be much more intentional about
我认为这项调查本身就是有帮助的，因为它列出了年轻人最关心、最让他们感到压力的事情。但同样重要的是，人们要明白，像社会支持这样的东西，我们有几十年的研究表明，我们生活中支持我们的人越多，我们的健康状况通常就越好，心理健康状况通常也越好，坦率地说，我们在生活中也会做得更好。因此，我们可以更有意识地
making sure that we are including people in our lives when we are going through very stressful periods. Social media, we talked about social media. Social media, again, can be a help or it can be something that causes stress, particularly when people are bullied through social media. So, Being able to limit that and to control that is an important way of managing stress. And then there are things that we can all do to just take care of ourselves. Getting enough sleep, eating right, exercising, those kinds of physical activities actually help us manage the level of stress that we're experiencing. And one bright spot the study found is that Generation Z is more likely to go see a therapist
确保在我们经历压力巨大的时期将人们纳入我们的生活中。我们谈到了社交媒体。社交媒体同样既可以是帮助，也可能是压力源，特别是当人们通过社交媒体受到欺凌时。因此，能够限制和控制这一点是管理压力的重要方式。此外，我们都可以做一些事情来照顾自己。充足的睡眠、健康的饮食、锻炼，这些身体活动实际上有助于我们管理所承受的压力水平。研究发现的一个亮点是，Z世代比千禧一代更有可能去看治疗师。
than the millennials. So is that a sign that the mental health stigma is going away? Wouldn't go there yet in terms of is mental health stigma going away. We know that mental health stigma is very powerful. It is universal. I was at a recent international conference. And the same kind of stigma that we have in the U.S. is really reflected around the world. So this is much bigger than even the United States.
那么，这是否意味着心理健康污名化正在消失？就心理健康污名化是否正在消失而言，我还不敢下结论。我们知道心理健康污名化非常严重，而且是普遍存在的。我最近参加了一个国际会议，我们美国存在的这种污名化在世界各地都有所体现。所以这不仅仅是美国的问题。
I do believe, though, that this younger generation is much more open to receiving services. And in fact, our survey says that. says that they're more likely to be open to receiving mental health services. And so I think that there is a glimmer of hope that people are becoming more open to receiving mental health services, that there's less stigma around those, around that generation and around these issues. But we do have a much bigger problem in our country and we have to be very concerned about how do we reduce the stigma and start to view mental health issues in the same way that we
不过，我确实认为年轻一代对接受服务更加开放。事实上，我们的调查显示，他们更有可能愿意接受心理健康服务。所以我认为有一线希望，人们对接受心理健康服务变得更加开放，围绕这一代人和这些问题，污名化正在减少。但我们在国内确实面临一个更大的问题，我们必须非常关注如何减少污名化，并开始以看待身体健康问题的方式来看待心理健康问题。
physical health issues. So only slightly more than half of Generation Z respondents said they were likely to vote in the midterm elections. Now we're past the elections now, but what does that say about why this generation chooses not to be active in politics? Well, I'm not a political scientist, but what we do know is that the older people are, the more likely they are to vote. And so Generation Z is not different than previous generations in that sense. We do also know that this generation has been is a little more likely to vote than previous generations of that age group so I think there's a little good news there that it looks like the trend is towards them being more active the fact that they're they're not
只有略多于一半的Z世代受访者表示他们可能会在期中选举中投票。现在选举已经结束了，但这说明了为什么这一代人选择不积极参与政治？嗯，我不是政治学家，但我们知道的是，人们年龄越大，投票的可能性就越大。因此，Z世代在这方面与前几代人没有什么不同。我们也确实知道，这一代人比该年龄段的前几代人更有可能投票，所以我认为这算是一个好消息，趋势似乎是他们变得更加活跃。事实上，他们没有
voting is not a typical one of the things that we are I think that is good about this generation is that you see a level of activism that we haven't seen in this generation in the past we saw that around the issue of school shootings We see that around other issues. And so one of the things that we know is that the more engaged you are around issues that you are feeling stress about, the more likely it is that you are able to manage that stress effectively. And so by voting, by being engaged in the political system, those are ways that actually help all of us deal with stress more effectively.
投票并不是典型的现象。我认为这一代人值得称道的一点是，你看到了我们过去从未见过的活跃程度。我们在校园枪击事件问题上看到了这一点，在其他问题上也看到了这一点。我们知道的一点是，你对感到压力的议题参与度越高，你就越有可能有效地管理这种压力。因此，通过投票，通过参与政治体系，这些实际上都是帮助我们所有人更有效地应对压力的方法。
And moving on to adults, in this survey compared to last year, compared to last year, the overall stress for adults went up significantly. So what does that tell us? Well, what it says is that people are really filling the effects of the environment, the political environment, the social environment. We were surprised last year when we saw 63% of Americans saying that they were stressed when it came to thinking about the future of the country. That number went from 63% last year to 69% and the current survey and so it means that the current environment isn't getting better it also could mean that people are being more sensitive to it but I suspect that it has more to do with the environment
接下来谈谈成年人，与去年相比，成年人的整体压力显著上升。这说明了什么？嗯，这说明人们确实感受到了环境、政治环境和社会环境的影响。去年我们看到63%的美国人表示在考虑国家未来时感到压力，这让我们感到惊讶。在当前的调查中，这个数字从去年的63%上升到了69%，这意味着当前的环境并没有好转。这也可能意味着人们对此更加敏感，但我怀疑这更多地与环境有关，
changing and becoming more entrenched around some of the incivility that we've seen as opposed to people being just more sensitive to that okay and about a quarter of all people respond to the survey said discrimination was also a source of stress and that was close to half of African-American adults and one-third of Hispanic adults. And which was surprising is that this rate is the highest since the question was first added to the survey in 2015. So can you speak to the challenges facing minority communities and people of color?
环境正在发生变化，并围绕我们所看到的一些不文明行为变得更加根深蒂固，而不是人们变得更加敏感。好的，大约四分之一的受访者表示歧视也是压力来源，在非裔美国成年人中这一比例接近一半，在西班牙裔成年人中为三分之一。令人惊讶的是，这是自2015年调查中首次加入该问题以来的最高比例。那么，您能谈谈少数族裔社区和有色人种面临的挑战吗？
Well, minority communities, people of color, have historically rated and experience more stress than other parts of the population. So that's pretty consistent. The results of this survey are showing that, and I think reinforcing this idea that the current political environment, current social environment is having an effect in terms of people's stress levels.
嗯，少数族裔社区和有色人种在历史上比人口的其他部分承受和经历了更多的压力。所以这相当一致。这项调查的结果显示了这一点，我认为也强化了这样一种观点，即当前的政治环境和社会环境正在影响人们的压力水平。
So not unexpected, but I think we have to be concerned then, again, about the current political environment, the current tone that we're in because that is having an impact on Americans in general, but also on minority groups in particular. And so overall, you advise people to seek out social supports, to get sleep, exercise, take care of themselves. Are there other coping strategies that you suggest for teens and adults? Well, I think it's very important to be to actively be engaged around the issues that people have concerns about and stress about. Since many of the things that we noted in the survey are political in nature, it's important then for people to be engaged in the political process,
所以这并不出人意料，但我认为我们必须再次关注当前的政治环境和当前的基调，因为这不仅对美国人整体产生了影响，对少数群体的影响尤为严重。总的来说，您建议人们寻求社会支持、保证睡眠、锻炼、照顾好自己。您还有其他建议给青少年和成年人的应对策略吗？嗯，我认为积极参与人们关心和感到压力的议题非常重要。由于我们在调查中提到的许多事情本质上是政治性的，因此人们参与政治进程非常重要，
for people to vote, for people to be active on issues that they care about, if that's immigration, if that's in the environment, whatever that issue is, for people to be actively involved in those issues actually helps them to manage their stress level. And so why does APA do this study? Well, we do this study because we know that there is a direct connection between the level of stress that we experience and then a whole series of health outcomes.
人们去投票，人们对他们关心的议题保持活跃，无论是移民问题还是环境问题，无论是什么议题，积极参与这些议题实际上有助于他们管理压力水平。那么美国心理学会为什么要进行这项研究？嗯，我们进行这项研究是因为我们知道我们所经历的压力水平与一系列健康结果之间存在直接联系。
And if we want the nation to be healthy, we know that stress can be an impediment to that, we think we're doing a public service by helping the public to understand, one, what are the things that people are stressed about, what are the levels of stress that people are experiencing, how is that changing? But more importantly, it gives us an opportunity than to talk about strategies, coping strategies, and things that people can put in place to really manage that stress and be much more conscious about the stress that they are experiencing.
如果我们希望国家健康，我们知道压力可能是实现这一目标的障碍。我们认为通过帮助公众了解人们对什么感到压力、人们正在经历的压力水平以及它是如何变化的，我们是在提供公共服务。但更重要的是，这让我们有机会讨论策略、应对策略以及人们可以采取的措施，以真正管理压力并更加自觉地意识到他们正在经历的压力。
And APA always offers plenty of resources on a variety of topics like stress in America or, you know, postpartum depression, you know, how to talk to children about traumatic events. So what does APA and psychologists around the country? What role do they play in helping ease people stress? Well, a variety of things. So one of the things is that when our stress gets to the point that it manifests in mental health challenges, seeing a psychologist can be very helpful. We also know that because we have psychologists all over the country who are aware of some of these issues,
美国心理学会总是提供关于各种主题的丰富资源，如《美国压力报告》、产后抑郁症，或者如何与孩子谈论创伤性事件。那么美国心理学会和全国的心理学家扮演什么角色来帮助缓解人们的压力？嗯，有很多方面。其中之一是，当我们的压力达到表现为心理健康挑战的程度时，看心理学家会非常有帮助。我们也知道，因为我们在全国各地都有了解这些问题的心理学家，
they can be very important resources to schools, to communities, giving lectures about ways that people can manage stress. You know, we really don't want people to need clinical intervention. So the more we can do to educate people about ways that they can manage stress, ways that they can mitigate stressors that are happening in their lives, lives, the less likely it is that people are going to run into challenges that really require clinical intervention. Clinical intervention is okay. That's why we train because we want to be able to do that, but we also want to be proactive and be preventative and do early intervention as well. And the APA website is a great tool for that.
他们可以成为学校和社区的重要资源，举办关于人们如何管理压力的讲座。我们真的不希望人们需要临床干预。因此，我们越能教育人们如何管理压力、如何减轻生活中发生的压力源，人们遇到需要临床干预的挑战的可能性就越小。临床干预是可以的，这就是我们接受培训的原因，因为我们希望能够做到这一点，但我们也希望采取主动、预防性的措施，并进行早期干预。美国心理学会的网站是一个很好的工具。
The APA website is a great tool for that. It has a lot of resources there. Our Stress in America section is very helpful, but we also have information on how you can reach a site. psychologist if you're looking for one and need one. Wonderful. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Evans. Thank you. I've enjoyed being here. If you want to learn more, please visit
美国心理学会的网站是一个很好的工具。上面有很多资源。我们的《美国压力报告》部分非常有帮助，我们还提供关于如果您正在寻找心理学家并需要帮助时如何联系他们的信息。太棒了。非常感谢您加入我们，埃文斯博士。谢谢。我很享受这次交流。如果您想了解更多信息，请访问
Stress in America.org. If you've been a long-time listener or viewer or are new to our show, please consider giving us a rating or write a review. We'd really appreciate it. We also like to hear from you directly, so if you have any questions or comments, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org.
StressinAmerica.org。如果您是我们的长期听众或观众，或者是我们节目的新朋友，请考虑给我们评分或写评论。我们将不胜感激。我们也喜欢直接听到您的声音，所以如果您有任何问题或意见，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。
That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-D-org. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue and Progress Notes. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit Speakingof Psychology.org to view more episodes and to see resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Caitlin Luna for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，如《APA期刊对话》和《进展笔记》。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们的节目。您也可以访问SpeakingofPsychology.org查看更多剧集并获取我们讨论主题的相关资源。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。